There are other things, other
than carbons, that might
branch off of the main chain.
And in this video, I want
to introduce you
to the alkyl halides.
And this is a situation where
one of the halogen elements,
and the halogen elements are
the second to last, or the
second to the right, or to the
right most column in the
periodic table.
Fluorine, chlorine,
bromine, iodine.
It's when one of these replace
one of the hydrogens attached
to a carbon.
So I've drawn some alkyl
halides here.
And let's think a little bit
of how to name them.
So like we name all of our
organic molecules so far, you
look for the longest chain
first. And the longest chain
that contains a double
bond if there is one.
In this case, there is no double
bond, so the longest
chain looks like this.
We start here and we
go over there.
Or we could go either way, but
this is the longest chain.
So it's one, two, three,
four, five, six,
seven, eight carbons.
Let me make sure of that.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight carbons.
And we want to start at the end
where we're going to run
into either some type of halide
first or some other
type of branch off of it.
Just something attached
to the carbon change
other than a hydrogen.
So we're going to start
at this end.
So it's one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
So we're dealing
with an octane.
Our main chain has eight
carbons, so we're
dealing with an octane.
And now we have to think about
these different halogens that
we have here.
So first we have a chlorine
at carbon number two.
So that's going to be 2-chloro,
is what we're going
to call that.
And we're going to put them in
alphabetical order and then
put them in front
of the octane.
And then this right here is
a-- it's on the fourth
carbon-- so it is a 4-bromo.
The actual element is
called bromine.
We change the ine to an
oro, so this is bromo.
The ine to an o, I should say.
So this is bromo.
And B comes before C, but we're
not done yet, because we
don't have just halides here.
We don't just have these
halogens over here.
We also have a methyl group.
We have one carbon sitting
over here.
So we don't want to
forget that guy.
So that right there,
that is a 5-methyl.
So when we write it all
out, we do it in
alphabetical order.
B takes precedence.
So this will be 4-bromo-- I'll
do it over here-- 4-bromo.
Then the next thing
we have is C.
So 4-bromo-2-chloro
-5-methyloctane.
Now if we take look at this
structure over here, our main
carbon branch, we only have two
carbons in it right here.
So we're dealing with
eth or ethane.
It's a single bond.
So this tells us that we're
dealing with an ethane.
And let's see what we
have attached to it.
We have a bunch of these
halogens attached to it.
We replaced a bunch of our
hydrogens with halogens.
So we have these
fluorines here.
And so we can start at
the end that has more
things attached to it.
So in this case, we have one,
two, three fluorines attached.
So this is going to start off
with-- and then fluorines,
well I'll just leave it
like that for now.
I was going to write it, but
then I have to remember,
you're going to have
to alphabetize it.
So let me just write out.
So at some point in our name,
we're going to have attached--
we're going to start
here-- that's going
to be the one carbon.
That is the one carbon.
That is the two carbon.
So at one point in our chain--
let me switch colors
actually-- we're going to have
one, two, three flourines.
So it's going to
be a trifluoro.
And they're all at
the one carbon.
So it's going to be
a 1,1,1-trifluoro.
That'll take care of those
three fluorines there.
And then we're going to have,
at some point in our name,
this bromo is attached to the
two carbon, so 2-bromo.
And then you also
have this chloro
attached to the two carbon.
So you're also going
to have 2,2-chloro.
So then you go in alphabetical
order.
B takes precedence.
And then you're going to go to
C, and then the trifluoro.
You ignore the tri.
But F still comes
after B and C.
So this is going to be 2-bromo
2-chloro-- I want to do that
same shade of green--
2-chloro, same idea.
And then we have
1,1,1-trifluoroethane.
Now I want to make one thing
clear, when you do this.
Double bonds, we saw on the
last video-- we learned a
little bit about alkenes-- still
take precedence over
everything.
So if we go to this original
compound-- this original
molecule up here-- if I were to
throw a double bond here.
So let's say I threw
a double bond.
Then all of a sudden that'll
change the naming mechanism.
First of all, we're not doing
with an octane anymore.
We're dealing with an octene.
So in this situation, the
chain-- we'll start at the end
closest to the double bond--
there's one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
So now this becomes 7-chloro.
This will be 5-bromo.
This is 4-methyl.
And this compound over here,
it will no longer be this
thing over here, because I've
added this double bond.
It will now be going in
alphabetical order.
It would be 5-bromo.
Let me have some space here.
It will be
5-bromo-7-chloro-4-methyl.
And then we have oct.
But it's an alkene,
so it's oct.
We have to specify where
we start our
double bond, oct-2-ene.
Now if we had two
double bonds.
Let's say we had a situation
where it was, maybe we had,
let's see we don't want to
put too many bonds here.
Carbon will only have
four bonds.
This carbon has three.
This hydrogen, we could have
double bond over here.
In that situation, we're going
to have-- and I actually
didn't specify it correctly in
the last video, so this is a
bit of a correction-- instead of
being 2-ene, this will now
be-- well let me make it instead
of being 2-ene when I
add that second carbon there, or
that second double bond, it
will now be-- scroll over to
the right a little bit-- it
will now be oct dash.
We have a double bond
at the two.
Starting at the two
and at the four.
2 comma 4.
And it's no longer
just an ene.
That was a mistake I did
in the last video.
I said hept, and I
just put an ene.
Now that I have two double
bonds, it's a diene.
So you don't want
to forget that.
That tells us that we have
two double bonds here.
Although it's kind of
obvious, because I'm
listing a 2 and a 4.
So it's a little
bit redundant.
2 and 4 diene.
So if you have it with these
two double bonds, we have
5-bromo-7-chloro
-4-methyl-oct-2,4-diene.
And the whole reason why I
introduced this is really to
make a bit of a correction.
Well to show you two things.
One, that the double bond takes
precedence when you are
deciding which direction
to number in.
And then also to correct a
little bit of a mistake in the
last video where I forgot to
put the di when I had two
double bonds.